à présent les les Ukrainiens les
premiers concernés par ces nouvelles
déclarations Gwendoline de bonob bonjour
vous êtes notre envoyé spécial à
carquive on est là tout près de la
frontière avec la Russie la présidente
ukrainienne a réagi ce matin
oui absolument et le président ukrainien
vous le dit mirzelinski qui reste solide
sur ses appuis voilà ce qu'il dit il y a
des nouvelles bruyantes de la part de la
Russie mais au fond qu'est-ce qu'on a
entendu de nouveau par rapport à ce que
l'on a déjà entendu auparavant le
président ukrainien qui dit que la
position de son pays ne va pas changer
en fonction de tel ou telle annonce
volody mirzelinski qui tient aussi à
remercier les occidentaux pour leur
réactions pour le fait et bien qu'ils
aient condamné l'intention de la Russie
d'organiser les référendums d'annexion
dans les régions du dombasme mais
également dans les territoires occupés
du sud de l'Ukraine c'est important car
avec l'annonce de ces référendums
d'annexion c'est avant tout le soutien
occidental les occidentaux que Vladimir
Poutine cherche à tester voir intimidé
tout simplement parce que une fois que
cette annexion sera formalisée par la
Russie et bien le Kremlin pourra dire
que une contrepensive Ukrainienne sur
ces régions est une attaque directe sur
le territoire russe et Vladimir Poutine
c'est très bien que les alliés de
l'Ukraine les États-Unis font très
attention à ce genre de choses à cette
logique d'escalade mais c'est la voix
qui a choisi Vladimir Poutine pour se
sortir d'une situation militaire qui
lutte qui est extrêmement défavorable au
trou Prusse sur le pays on vous l'avait
dit il y a eu cette contre-offensive qui
a permis au troubles ukrainienne de
regagner 3000 km² de leur territoire et
grâce à cette contre-offensive qui se
poursuit et bien les troubles
ukrainiennes progressent notamment dans
le combat c'est ça pour Vladimir Poutine
et bien c'est une menace stratégique il
ne peut pas se permettre de ne pas
réagir alors concernant également cette
mobilisation partielle cette
mobilisation de réserviste nous nous
sommes entretenus à ce sujet avec deux
gradés
Ukrainiens ce qu'ils disent c'est que
évidemment 300000 l'homme de plus des
réservistes certains qui ont une
qualification ça peut changer les
opérations sur le terrain il va falloir
s'adapter mais ce qu'ils disent c'est
que ça ne va pas changer les problèmes
structurels qui qui ont été mis à jour
les problèmes structurels de l'armée
russe à savoir un commandement
défaillant une infanterie également
défaillante et puis le fait également
que les Russes les troupes russes n'ont
pas la supériorité aérienne donc les
militaires Ukrainiens restent concentrés
sur leur tâches et continuent et pense
bien continuer la contre-offensive qui
est toujours en cours Gwendoline de Bono
envoyé spécial France 24 à carquive
Merci à VOUS Gwendoline et bonjour
Pierre Azan